[Music]
McDonald's is truly an icon of the 20th
and 21st century today we are trying
bloody Aussie Mac is that you can only
get in Australia who don't know I don't
know I'm a little bit nervous oh my god
I mean it's the Patriot that makes it
really awesome favourite yeah it's a bit
of a sweetness that hits you if someone
gave me this burger I wouldn't assume
was from McDonald's I would assume it's
from the corner shop a fried egg with a
good pace of bacon on top of it and made
like that he's like couldn't get more
Australian Australians love double mate
it's almost now the Aussie burger but a
little bit of sauce me 810 attempt you
know I want Motty sauce she's talking
about ketchup
yes headship
[Music]
no more yet these are a very traditional
Mexican breakfast I'm ready for
disappointment I like it a lot and I
don't like regular Monyetta so seems
like if you were stoned in another
country and you were trying to make
money at it you would make these modules
are made with this traditional Mexican
bread called belittle like a real aim
it's a sort of hard on the outside soft
on the inside breath and it's like you
couldn't do this with like Molly your
breath
when you combine 1/3 or what's known of
harmony before the corner they stop
[Music]
I don't think it needs the extra bun
yeah me either
yeah can anyone really describe what
McDonald's tastes like the cheese and
the vegetables ratio is great but then
you have this interesting middle bun
that kind of screws everything up but
the funny thing is you could take this
top half off and just eat it like burger
my notes would be the middle bun
unnecessary but I liked it
oh okay this looks interesting it's got
all this all these little marks little
bit dry you're about to choke on it oh
the sauce on the bottom I didn't like
when they do that I was like my sauce on
the top
the chicken is quite nice there's a
little bit of a kick by Cheeburger
I also got a bit of smokiness then I
like chicken I think it's okay
I think I'd order this again
I'm a Muslim Allah bestows method now we
need to know those boots come with a
pitiable Cibola I suppose now let's
shade up babe I feel like McDonald's is
like Britney Spears even if you deny
that you don't like her you do like her
mcDonald says rape Mexican food is great
the both of them combined damn well
McDonald's you're replicating good
Australian life